I'm Arthur Brooks a professor at Harvard
University and the happiness columnist
at the Atlantic I'm here today to answer
your questions on Twitter this is
happiness support
[Music]
first up at simpi Samantha who just
found out that the key to happiness is a
good sleep schedule who knew well the
secret to happiness is not lots of sleep
or even a good sleep schedule one of the
funny things about diet nutrition
exercise sleep they don't actually bring
happiness but they do lower unhappiness
which can be your problem now it sounds
like I'm splitting hairs right most
people think that unhappiness is the
opposite of Happiness it's not they're
actually processed in different
hemispheres of the brain happiness on
one side unhappiness on the other the
right side is negative basic emotions
and the way that we know this is because
the left side of the face which is
controlled by the right side of the
brain is more active when we're feeling
negative emotions so simply Samantha my
guess is that you know you've got
someone happiness in your life and look
we all do some of us have higher
negative feeling levels than others if
you've got that and you want some relief
that's what's going to bring it so it
won't make you happier it's not the
secret to happen this but it sure is
good for having less unhappiness have a
good night's sleep
queen of fire
85. does anyone ever experience
depression or uncertainty after
achieving a goal oh yes yes they do this
is the the real riddle of Happiness this
is the satisfaction dilemma in a
nutshell yeah if I get that watch I'm
gonna love it forever I get that car I
get that house I get that relationship I
get that job that money that fill in the
blank it's going to be so great and it
is for a minute now there's
neurophysiology behind this too there's
a neuromodulator in the brain called
dopamine and you want it you work for it
you're gonna get it dopamine dopamine
dopamine you got it oh oh
I guess I need to start again
here's a it's just a little tiny way to
think about how to solve that problem
you I everybody mother nature teaches us
that to get satisfaction and keep it you
need to have more that's the wrong model
your real satisfaction is all the things
you have divided by all the things that
you want now you can try to increase
your satisfaction permanently by having
more
or you can work on the denominator of
halves divided by once you can work on
on wanting less that turns out to be the
right formula kitoff or Shake It Off
shake it off I got it Shake It Off
masks how do I practice gratitude when
all I feel is sadness frustration and
confusion back to your question how do I
feel gratitude you decide to be grateful
is the bottom line the brain kind of is
in three parts it's not exactly this way
but but just for reference there's the
ancient part that has all your motor
functions and breathing and brain stem
and spinal column then you got the
middle part your limbic system that
takes signals from the outside world and
takes a kind of machine language and
turns it into feelings that happen to
you and then from there it delivers
those signals into the neocortex of the
brain the wrinkly part on the outside of
your brain the most evolved and
amazingly human of which is the
prefrontal cortex a bumper of brain
tissue right behind your forehead and it
gets these emotions and you decide what
they mean and what you're supposed to do
now a lot of people go through life and
just kind of a limbic State being
delivered emotions and if you're a sort
of a limbic person feeling like you're
managed by these things kind of hoping
for the best then your limbic system is
in charge but that's not your only
option you can be in charge yourself but
what you have to do is to experience
your emotions in the prefrontal cortex
of your brain and it's a very simple
process if you put your mind to it it's
called metacognition metacognition means
being aware of your emotions and your
thinking this is what humans are
uniquely available to do my dog Chucho
he's not metacognitive he can't be he
feels it he does it he sees the cookie
he eats the cookie but I can actually
deliver that information to my
prefrontal cortex and make an executive
decision about what I'm going to do
notwithstanding my feelings here's what
I ask my students to do at Harvard I ask
them to make a gratitude list on Sunday
nights I make that they make a list of
the five things they're most grateful
for that every night during the rest of
the week take five minutes and look at
your gratitude list Sundays update your
list in 10 weeks you're going to be
between 15 and 25 percent happier
because you decided to be grateful you
manage your emotions so they didn't
manage you and if you do that it's Game
Changer being in charge you're never
going to be the same
Haze 1136 pretty rabbit as I lay here I
wonder what is the true meaning of
happiness happiness is actually a
combination of three identifiable things
that we all need and we all want in both
balance and abundance these are the
macronutrients of Happiness your
Thanksgiving dinner is protein
carbohydrates and fat well your
happiness is enjoyment satisfaction and
purpose enjoyment is is not just
pleasure it's it's pleasure with
Consciousness it's using your prefrontal
cortex satisfaction is the joy that you
get from a job well done it's your
reward for striving for working for even
suffering purpose what's that well
that's really a question of finding
coherence in your life finding goals in
your life finding significance in your
life if you have those three things you
have happiness George styles
asks is happiness connected to having a
purpose purpose is literally one of the
macronutrients of happiness but it's a
weird one it's actually hard to figure
out even what it is if you're feeling
like life doesn't have enough purpose
that life doesn't have enough meaning
answer the following two questions why
am I alive
and for what would I be willing to die
if you don't have an answer to one or
both of those questions you're going to
have an existential crisis and you need
to go in search with your life of an
answer to those two questions I'm not
going to tell you what those answers are
they're different for different people
so yes does purpose lead to happiness oh
yeah how do you find your purpose answer
those two questions find the answer to
those two questions that's your
assignment
can social media cause depression yes so
it seems here's the basic bottom line
social media is like the junk food of
social life if High calories low
nutrition you're starving for this
neuropeptide called oxytocin it bonds
people together you get almost none of
it when you don't have touch and eye
contact but you crave more and more
social contact when you've been on
social media for so long so you binge it
it's basically like binging french fries
and then wondering why you feel crummy
and you're gaining weight but you're not
getting your nutrition here's the deal
if you're going to use social media make
sure it only ever comes implements your
in-person relationships and you use it
very sparingly I'm talking about a total
of 30 minutes a day across all platforms
and never ever ever substituting for an
in-person friendship if it substitutes
for any friendship or goes outside of
those bounds it's going to lower your
happiness Puja escal got to get the
middle initial I know how does age
affect happiness and she encloses a
graph and what it does is it looks at
different ages the average happiness
level in a particular country at a
particular time and it looks the same
every place what do you think is going
to happen let's just say you're in your
late 20s are you going to be happier
unhappier in 10 years now most people
watching me are optimists most people
think they're going to be happier at
38th and there were 28th and the reason
is because they all these have these
goals and they think that they're going
to meet their goals most people think
they're going to get happier as they get
older and it's going to reach a Max
point and then it's going to head back
down again the truth is exactly the
opposite most people on average they get
a slight diminution of their happiness
from their early 20s until they're late
40s early 50s but it's like eight to
seven on a one to ten scale this is not
a huge problem noticeable but not
horrible then in your early 50s it turns
around and you start back up again and
almost everybody actually gets
increasing happiness from their early
50s until about 70 except two groups
people who have unremediated mental
illness and people have untreated
substance use disorders so if this is
you get treated for anxiety and
depression and mood disorders and get
treated for addiction all right next
question comes from
at laughing all the way how do we adjust
our expectations as we age that's a good
one one of the things that actually gets
better and better and better as you age
is your expectations about the future
because you understand how things work
there's this tyranny that people don't
understand until they're usually a
little after 50 years old they think
that if they get that thing that they
want they're going to get it and they're
going to enjoy it and and it's never
going to go away and then it does they
also think that if something bad happens
to them that they're going to stay in a
bad mood or sad or angry or afraid
forever here's what you learn after 50.
nothing lasts and it doesn't matter
there's a thing in that all biologists
talk about which is homeostasis the
tendency of every biological process to
go back to its equilibrium well it works
emotionally as well your anger your
sadness your disgust your fear your joy
your interest those things don't last
for good and for bad your heart is
broken it won't last when you figure
that out this is power and if you
harness that every year is better than
the last or it can be next up this runs
from father poster and I'm just going to
take a wild guess that this is actually
not a priest how do I transcend
from my mortal anguish sounds to me like
Father poster is a little afraid of
dying but we're all afraid of our own
version of dying there's a meditation
that the theravada Buddhists do if you
go to a monastery a Buddhist Monastery
in the Southern Tier of Asia especially
East Asia and Thailand or Vietnam or
Myanmar you'll find pictures of corpses
in various states of Decay and that the
monks have to ponder and they have to
say that is me and that is me what are
they doing they're doing what's called
the Marana Sati death meditation walk
yourself through that why because you're
going to accustom yourself to that sort
of surreal experience of your own death
as you see it how do I transcend my
mortal anguish by leaning into my mortal
anguish you beat fear by by experiencing
the fear and making it ordinary and it
will no longer be a ghost and it will no
longer be a problem
at third eye pryan because I've been
working on being
present
to be present means to be here now
that's the words that Ram Das used to
talk about we have a special kind of
language that we put on that now it's
called being mindful mindfulness is hard
because we're Time Travelers you're
thinking about the past you're thinking
about the future the average person by
the way spends 30 to 50 of their time
thinking about the future that's
unbelievable you're not here now think
about how much you do that by the way
you go on vacation you're like I'm gonna
I'm gonna make some memories so I'm
going to take a picture picture picture
you're thinking about now as if it were
the past in the future when you're
looking back on the present that's
unbelievable time travel we do it all
the time here's the problem
you missed your life you missed it you
know the great Vietnamese Buddhist monk
tick not Han y'all have to read the
miracle of mindfulness because it starts
off with him describing what it's like
to wash the dishes I'm washing the
dishes and I'm conscious of washing the
dishes because if I don't think about
washing the dishes I will not be present
in the act of washing the dishes that
means working on being a mindful person
maybe it's with meditation maybe it's
with prayer maybe it's with therapy and
sitting with your hands folded on your
lap looking out the window of the train
saying I am sitting on the train right
now
because I don't want to miss my life
finally shimeri underscore AAA wants to
know the definition of wisdom
psychometricians those who study
different forms of intelligence find
that we have a thing called fluid
intelligence early on in our 20s and 30s
the ability to focus to innovate to to
solve problems to think quickly people
tend to Peak in knowledge professions at
their their ability to solve problems to
innovate to focus working memory in
their late 30s but there's another curve
behind it called crystallized
intelligence which increases through
your 40s and 50s and 60s and stays high
in your 70s and 80s it's the wisdom
curve the essence of wisdom is teaching
is mentoring it's leading teams it's
recognizing patterns it's understanding
what things really mean and using that
information in service of other people
and it gets better and if you choose to
cultivate it it can make your life as
happy as it could possibly be as you get
older that's not only the consolation of
age that's the promise of wisdom well it
looks like that's all all we've got for
today those are your questions I hope
you've learned a lot from this time I
hope you've enjoyed it I hope you're a
little bit happier but here's the key
thing if you really want to lock it in
here's the secret you got to think about
it and you gotta adopt new habits in
your life and most of all here's the
most important part you got to share it
go share it then you'll never lose it
thanks for taking some time with me
today
[Music]